QUORUM IS HIGHLY CALDERON BURKE
HERE. GROW CHU GRAY MANSE
MELENDEZ MULLIN. PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE RIVAS. HERE KING
MADAM LIA WE HAVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE'RE DOING VOTE ONLY
WILL START WITH AB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE ROSE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATION
WITH THE AMENDMENTS TO LOWER
THE CREDIT PERCENTAGE 250% AND
DELAY THE CREDITS OPERATION BY
ONE YEAR. DO I HAVE A MOTION. A
SECOND. YEAH SECOND. RIVAS OKAY
WITH WITH WE GOT A SECOND IS
RIVAS- WITH THAT WITH ONLY CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE AYE BURKE AYE ROW ROW RHU
GRAY MAYES MULLIN THIS ONE JUST
AYE MULLIN NINE AYE.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS NO
QUIRK NO WORK NO RIVAS
RIVERSIDE. SOME CALL IT NEEDS
ONE THAT THOSE ON CALL NEEDS
ONE LIVING IS SECOND FILE ITEM
AB EIGHT FIFTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. TWO I
HAVE A MOTION. PLEASE TELL ME
CALDERON. BURKE HI BURKE AYE
BRO WELL I TO GRAY MAYES
MELINDA'S WONDERS AYE MULLIN
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE RIVAS RIVAS AYE TING.
THE BILL THAT BILL IS OUT. SIX
SEVEN THREE SEVEN ZERO. WELL
WAY FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE
GIVE THEM A FEW MINUTES. OKAY.
MR GRAY'S ABSENT SO WAIT FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS. IT
WILL HAPPEN IN THE DAYS AND
TING I'M MR TO THANK YOU RIGHT
NINE AND- THANK YOU. THERE WAS.
ONLY. THE
. MISSPELLING WILL
LIVE ON A LIVE THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM WHEN AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO OUR
CHIU I. TING TING I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ON TO THE FILE ITEM TO AB EIGHT
FIFTY ALL THE ABSENTEES CHILL
CHIU I TING TING THANK YOU SO
LET'S CHECK MR MAYES. THANK. I
WAS IN COLLEGE. OKAY. WE'LL
GIVE THE LAST MEMBER FIVE
MINUTES TO GET TO COMMITTEE.
FIVE MINUTES FROM NOW
. OF FIVE
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
EIGHT FIFTY PASSES. THE SEVENTY
TWO. SEVEN LATER AT LET'S SAY
THAT AGAIN THE ISLAND ONE AB
FIVE THIRTY FIVE PASSES. YEAH.
THREE WHY THAT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
OR IS NOT HIM INTO. OR SEVENTY
TWO THAT PILOT OF PASSES AND
THEN FILE ITEM TO AB FIFTY
PASSES. THIS. HOLES YEAH. NINE
ZERO OKAY OKAY. BOB. IT WAS
CALLED A SOPHOMORE. WHAT FORTY
SEVEN AFTER
. REVENUE TAXES
ADJOURNED